Nó là Vinh Giang, gặn nhận như thế
thì chúng ta sẽ...
Càng làm làm toa với tinh thần cộng đồng này in trong giá hội
Mà lại một cái giá hội, phát triển bên vực
Công ai bị bò lại trái sao?
Là, đáng chứng sợ, cho những uống cá nhân này là những tất thịt
là người có việc vì không đồng mà không mà mình...
Gó là những cái spot light nhưng mà hạp tinh chắc là...
Những người đe ngó là trong trái tinh của mình, cho những xuyện của mình nó chắc của sắp của mình
Họ sẽ như người hạch, bây giờ tự ra thịt đến cái cung
Chào đi hôm hại để cho một cái kịch lấy mà cho đi hảo dễ bà trịt
Sự mỗi đúc đi ở bên, phát triển.
Bó có chuyện được Vinh Giang không nay là một mình chứng
Thì con người tóc đẹp hành động, Thì con đồng sẽ thay đổi
Thương mình ac tròi hành nghi cú trong hài lắm
Không chỉ tóm Vinh thành tư, mạc có tất lấy mình tinh, về một Việt Nam sáng, nhân văn và tịt gửi